this show is but with a cash cow the
number one finance app in the App Store
on top of creating the best way to spin
send and save money last 18 months
developing a tongue twister for their
favorite friends say it six times
quickly blessing what is this with good
financial instincts for 48 hours all
right we have a tongue twister we're
gonna try to say cash app chaps chug
canned crushed crap go Benton kanna-chan
stars can crush crowd six times you say
it six times
that's chaps chug can crush cab chap
apps can crush crab trap chops chug can
crush crab cash up chaps jug can crush
crab catch up Jeff chug can't curse crab
cash up chaps Jim by their side over the
cash app please and use the promo code
Whitney and not only we insulin receive
$10 but cash up will also donate $10 to
The Trevor Project an amazing
organization that provides Protective
Services to lgbtqia+ youths across
America don't forget the promo code
Whitney when you download the cash app
to the App Store today
[Music]
do you like to use headphones or not oh
yeah I do actually
do you like you I still haven't decided
oh you know what let's not because it's
I didn't know he's gonna be filmed it
looks better with it is filmed without
him without without him yeah I sometimes
do it because it makes me feel like I'm
more focused or something I really will
see if I'm recording an audio book or
something I wear them because they help
me hear myself yeah
so when I'm recording I use them yeah
sometimes well let's play it by ear
yeah we'll try them take them off for me
it's like a Pavlovian thing it's like
now it's time to focus okay if this
thing is squeezing your head you need to
pay attention alright can you tell how
intimidated by I am by the fact that
you're here based on all the makeup I
have around me really I've been putting
makeup on for the past like 20 minutes
and if you really anticipation of you
arriving it's so funny they all think
I'm insane I was acting like a 15 year
old girl waiting for a boy to show up I
was pacing around my house and looking
out the window waiting for you to show
up really yeah gee that's nice my very
big fan oh that's so nice we just say I
didn't gosh I never expect that really
yeah that's wild
I mean expect it like they expect to be
on the New York Times bestseller list
but I expect that you know when I go
somewhere to anybody to know who I am
really all three things final those
books that put you on a best-seller list
well like I do shows in LA sometimes
yeah and it's funny because I met uh
Matthew whiner you know yeah and he and
he said oh I've come to see you a bunch
of times and he said it's always TV
writers in the audience and I knew oh
yes
never occurred to me huge you're all of
our hero never ever occurred to me
because I meet you know I saw in bulks
and I asked people and I never meet them
I mean I never meet any buddy who were
you never
and what their occupation has no idea
all the time but I've never met anybody
who said oh I write for this or that
show so I guess they don't stand in line
you know so oh that's interesting they
probably got the backstage passes what's
the weirdest thing anyone's ever asked
you to sign I don't I don't like to do
that
you know like somebody Oh a guy came up
and I did notice right I mean he
couldn't help but notice that one of his
arms and did just below the elbow and it
kind of looked like a chicken wing
uh-huh kind of petered out it wasn't
like and then he said we saw in my stump
and then I had to act like him stuff you
know of course I'd already seen it the
performance begins yeah and so I said
okay sure it bores if somebody said
would you sign my arm I wouldn't do it
just because I'm not a celebrity
so I so I don't sign things and I feel
like signing books I'm comfortable right
and then a lot of people now you know
they listen to audiobooks on their phone
so we use on my phone it's like okay we
son my Kindle yeah but what a lot of
people do now and I don't I don't know
if it's uh where they got this idea but
they'll come and say you signed this
book three times already when you sign
it again and he wanted and a couple
times I've said I've said you're the
20th person that I'd asked me to do that
and then they look like you slapped them
because they think that it's original
and it's far from original yeah and it's
not a money thing I just don't want to
do it I don't think it's funny and so
now I say I'll sign a piece of paper and
you can do whatever you want with it
you know do you ever feel like people
need a lot from you like you know what I
don't have that much to do so I'm happy
to give it doesn't mean like I don't
ever feel this is author who I met and
she in the Netherlands and she said oh I
can't sign books for more than ten
minutes because people tell me stories
and I'm just drained and then I can't do
anything for the next three days and I'm
like
that's not a problem for me I mean
people tell me horrible things and I
sleep like a baby like it doesn't bother
me in the least bit and I never think of
a vet in a vampiric way yeah
it's everything I ever dreamed of is
that people would stand in line to talk
to me and whatever they want to talk
about is fine and I'm happy to sit there
my record is ten and a half hours Wow
and if there's one other 400 people in
line I would have said okay because it's
all I ever wanted and I'm really telling
truth I don't see a downside to it I do
when people aren't paying attention and
you're completely nice to somebody and
you're engaging and then they complain
about what you wrote in the book oh my
gosh yep and it's and it's like I was
nice yep
I did this thing where I was drawing I I
was it's not so bad I was drawing people
naked right I said oh this is your
portrait naked and I drew this woman's
portrait naked and her daughter came to
me and said my mother had breast cancer
and you drew her with those drooping
breasts the aedra and and her mother was
already like Annie doesn't mean so I was
drawing her mother under gravity yeah
and I didn't have anything to do with
that and I was talking to the mother and
I was drawing a picture in her book and
I was so I just I just felt like if the
mother came and if I just signed my name
and pushed the thing back to her and
then you want to complain great you have
every right to but I thought we were
having a moment you know that's so
interesting it I think also I try to
think of the kind of people that will
come up and talk to you or or you know I
think mine's probably a little bit
different but these are probably very
sensitive people
you know these I try to just always stay
in that mode we think okay the kind of
people that are sitting here waiting are
probably a sensitive emotional group of
people that need a lot from me and I
just have to forgive whatever their
behavior is
well I remember like I went and saw
somebody when I lived in Chicago and she
was a comedian slash actress more than a
writer but she put a book out and I went
to get her book and it was a lot of
money for me at the time and I got up
there and she was talking to her I guess
maybe it was a publicist and she said
yeah I don't know there's really not
that much doing this town she just saw
my book and pushed it back to me
and I and I felt so betrayed by that and
I just thought when it's my turn and I'm
the author I'm never ever going to do
that ever
that's so cool but then like you know
like I said like my agent called one day
and said I got a letter from this woman
and she's crazy
and she said she came with her 15 year
old daughter and you gave the daughter a
condom I'm sad and you told the daughter
you didn't want to be responsible for
her getting pregnant and so she could
only use this for anal sex and I said
yeah I remember her like remember
exactly but I said it in a nice way
no it's very helpful I mean I was I was
you around I was 16 but it saved me a
lot of Planned Parenthood visits but the
line had been cut off right because I
had I do it before and after the show so
the line been cut off and it was time
for me to go start the show and this
woman said you can do one more you know
like there's always that person you can
do one more and and it was I noticed it
was a young girl you know ages 15 and
then I thought okay I can do yeah you're
right I can do one more and then I
engage the girl and I talked to her and
then the mother got so upset and it's
like you know what I mean like I went
out of my way and I was you know it's
friendly and yeah and I don't expect the
daughter yeah to have anal sex with I
mean I it's such a crazy thing to say
it doesn't like there's a ridiculous
clause like yes there was something I
wrote for The New Yorker one time and
then I said can we get in trouble and we
get and they said no that's what you
proposed is so ridiculous that nobody
would be allowed to take it seriously
and
to me is what that is and if she was
wearing a bonnet you know and she was
wearing clothes she had made herself on
the loom that her family has and she
rode to the came to the reading in a
buggy I would not I would not have said
that you know she lived in a big city I
figured she'd heard a famous that
parents are in such denial about the
Internet
it's just so funny it's like oh you
think this is bad wait till your kid
watches a movie or sees the Internet
you're really gonna be stressed out well
but it's different for you because you
like when you're meeting people is it
more like a stage door situation when
I'm meeting people I think I I think I
put myself in a situation I have so much
gratitude for it I do I'm like you I
never in a million years thought anyone
would wait in line to want to talk to me
or sign something and I'd stay as long
as I can always but I do thing with me
people often try to be funny and they
end up hurting my feelings
hmm it's pretty common hey kind like
okay you know I think if you do a
certain type of comedy I did the roasts
a lot you know people really want to
come up and you know insult me or make
laugh and it just ends up making me
hurting but breaking my heart sometimes
but you know I'm so intimidated about
doing this because I just watched your
master class and I loved the section on
how to ask good questions so I feel like
I need to open on do you know a lot of
doctors I don't know enough I mean the
doctors that I'm getting to know lately
are like working on me but I but I don't
have friends who are doctors but that's
exactly the kind of friends yeah that
you need but I met a doctor at Party
mm-hmm and pardon me um I met a doctor
at a party in England and I hope that
might lead to something but I haven't
seen him since then but I'd love to I've
been meeting a lot of doctors at
readings because I a doctor came in
tell me about somebody who'd subbed
dildo up his ass and the door shut
behind it and then and then that happens
apparently you stick something 3/4 of
the way up and the asshole says I'll
take that and it just sucks it right up
and interaction and so it's in your
master class I would have loved to see
nothing well then the guy tried to get
it out with a coat hanger oh no no and
then that didn't work so he cut the cone
hanger with with metal clippers and went
with another coat hanger okay and where
was this Florida I have it written down
in my diary the state but and I said
what did the guy say he's and the guy
said oh I tripped
so he came in like to make it sound like
he was like maybe bringing the dildo to
his wife and he had hangers you know key
and then he fell down the stairs and
then the next thing you know put another
big excuse people say oh I accidentally
sat on it like a thermos that was coated
with Vaseline yeah I was gonna say this
took a lot of Lube eat up a lot of
orchestrating a lot of practice and so
Don and so I've met a couple nurses who
send me pictures now chilling pictures
like one picture and it was somebody
maybe they were that we're diabetic and
they had a hole in the top of their foot
but you could see the tendons and their
foot but what was interesting about it
and and she said these people only say
oh it just happened two days ago and
like there's no way it just happened two
days ago but they let it go which is
exactly what I would do when people lie
to them they have to just yes and and
improvise with them but I would let
something like that go like if I noticed
a big growth on my shoulder I'd say
it'll go away tomorrow and luckily I
don't where I heard this but people who
are married or in a relationship live
longer and it's because their partner's
them into going to the doctor so
interesting I I love the story about the
tumor you gave to a snapping turtle I
did a lot of research on why you're not
allowed to keep your own tumor why it's
apparently state by state
but normally if there's a some kind of
disease in it that's their main concern
is that some sort of
disease you could contract and also
because they want to do research on it
but there is a website called store your
tumour calm really I really screwed up
my algorithm research like this and
there is a law where you cannot keep a
Native American body part but you are
technically allowed to keep your own
body part so I really want to get into
what happened with that term you can't
keep no a Native American it's a law
body part know something about the
Native American graves and such there
was a law passed but you should be able
to keep your own so the Native American
graves protection and repatriation act
can you imagine if I even mispronounce
that in front of him makes it illegal to
own or trade Native American remains
otherwise a few states restrict owning
or selling human body parts I think it
was Georgia huh I got very into this I
want to get your tumor back from that
snapping turtle so yeah I got very very
into this um but you know a lot of
doctors now dentists they won't give you
your tooth oh that's interesting when we
were young you know they'd only give it
to you yeah but now they say could you
could get flesh-eating bacteria from
your own tooth which I think that's
overreacting I think they could put it
in some bleach and you'd be fine so
there is now no US federal law
preventing the ownership of body parts
unless they're Native American I got
very interests wait the general rule is
you have custody of it you were
considered the owner of your body parts
as long as they're inside once it's
outside we have some reasonable
expectation about what's going to be
done with it so they're only years as
long as they're on the inside I'm so
curious did the snapping turtle take it
right away uh yeah I mean it was just
food yeah and there's nothing you know a
snapping turtle won't like something
girls are like foxes like a fox is never
gonna say I'm sorry that's too far gone
for me there's no such thing right it's
too far going for a fox
I'm I got very into this because in your
master class you talk about the art of
asking
which for any artist is the most
important thing and I'm pretty weird at
parties because I tend to go straight
for like what meds are you on like I
always skip small talk and people really
don't like it but I'm like I'm here to
get jokes I'm not here to socialize you
know that's pretty much the only way I
can attune to people but I got super
fascinated by this because whenever
someone tells me like oh that party was
boring or I didn't have any fun or I
don't like that person I always think
you just didn't ask the right question
right I do too you know and and one of
my favorite questions to ask people and
I'm just curious if this is too far it's
like asking someone like like what do
you take any prescriptions like I always
ask that if I was at a party and
somebody came up and said do you take
any prescriptions I would be so I would
be so happy and I mean I think gosh
that's a good question what a good
icebreaker and if I were taking
something let's say that I was
embarrassed about I would just lie and I
would leave it off the list or I'll just
open with it I'll normally go like oh
the prozac hasn't kicked in yet and then
they feel to be like oh yeah neither is
mine and I just switch to bulb uterine
or whatever and you can sort of really
start to dig in but I was saying to
someone a while ago I lived mainly in
the south of England and and England's
different than most countries like their
people are warm in the north and kind of
colder in the south and we're and
especially growing up in North Carolina
and we have to say hello to everybody
and you have to engage in a lot of you
know chitchat if I'm walking and I'm in
the country and I see somebody in the
front yard and I say hello they'll turn
their back on me they will not even say
hello to me
and so's and and I this is a fitness
center I've been going to for nine years
in this village I don't know anybody
there I've been going for nine years no
one's ever asked me my name the people
who work at a front desk have never said
anything to me um like oh christmas is
coming I mean nothing and there was a
guy and he was like in his 80s and I
said are you a doctor and he said no
what makes you think that I said you
look just like a doctor I've seen you
for years I was assumed you're a doctor
and he said no I used to do this and
then I did this before so easy
view over and then this friend of mine
who's a fireman said I should have said
now just I just have one more question
why are you such a cunt I also love can
you explain to me in I've seen a lot of
English comedians come over and when
they say they don't realize the cunt
over here you guys can't say but bitch
in England is like the cunt of England
right actually continent Lynn is Fanny
and when Americans say oh I have it in
my fanny pack they can't believe what
they just heard so Fanny is the English
version of cunt hear a Fanny is a pussy
okay sickly because if Fanny is a tush
here right right yeah but there it's
like saying pussy
okay so it's but can't is not even like
that's nothing answer to dis million and
the French use it that way too
it just means an idiot right and so it
makes me always make it makes me laugh
every time I hear it in here it's you
know it plays differently here is the
probably the roughest thing you can say
to someone oh we won't Minh at least
right but you wouldn't call a man
account here and that's what's funny in
England is cuz I hear more men being
called conscious than women yeah it's
like hey buddy over there or a why you
being such a con like why are you being
such a and it's almost like it's not why
being such an asshole it's like why are
you being such an idiot
and then Fanny would be why are you
being such a Fanny that's like you're
not know you would more say like you
know I met this girl and she's stuck on
entire 30 watt light bulb up her Fanny
it would be more like that I don't get
out with a coat hanger and then bitch
over there
like what's the roughest thing you can
say to a woman over there gosh
if you want to verbally abuse a woman in
England how would you do it in case uh
well I mean they have so many words like
that we don't like different words for a
slot yeah that we don't have like call
somebody a slag or call somebody up gosh
that's a really good question I mean um
and pretty over there is fit right he's
very fit
fit that's like handsome oh gosh I don't
know that I've ever noticed that maybe
um uh golly I mean I know I tried to say
cunt on the BBC and there was a time
when you could but now you can't and I
used the word on stage the perfect it
was a diary entry and this woman went on
a date with a man she met online and he
he'd never been married he was like in
his 50s and he said I guess you could
say I have a fear of the c-word and she
leaned across the table and said cunt
and he meant commitment and and then I
read that in London and a woman came and
slapped a piece of paper on the counter
and said here's where you can send an
apology letter for using that word but I
thought it was a perfect way of using
them because you're quoting a woman not
spoofs a ditch by accident and if
there's no pure way I think she's wrong
use that word and look I mean it's it's
such a wild time I mean I remember you
were talking somewhere about how at some
comedy festival there was a was it a
female comedian who was told not to self
deprecated yeah or to not to criticize
her own body yeah that really grinds my
gears you know it's you're you can
you're allowed to be offended by
something you're allowed to have
feelings about something that doesn't
mean the artist needs to change their
behavior I mean it's to me kind of a
scary time that people think that their
feedback matters it's funny because I
just wrote something about that
and yes in this moment it was a woman's
Comedy Festival and she wasn't allowed
to make fun of her own body and that
same night that I read that I listen to
some old toady fields records and when
tawny Fields was a staple on TV when I
was growing up and it's like we were all
run to watch how he feels and her whole
thing was about how fat and how ugly she
was her whole act right and I listened
to her best of album and she says just
once I'd like to open newspaper and see
a headline totie Fields raped in an
alley
you imagine can you imagine saying that
today I mean but a lot of people to
understand that the that is how the
audience feels like you you know are
self-aware you have to be able to
address things that the audience are
thinking it's only to get power over
them I think people don't understand
your disempowering yourself nor not this
is how I'm gaining my power trust us
that drives me totally insane and I was
thinking more about questions I've been
thinking about this ever since I watched
your episode and one of my favorite
questions to ask a woman is what color
lipstick is that because it will turn
into like a 25-minute spiral
mmm you learned so much it's like it I
had to mix these two colors and this
one's discontinued and this one is my
mom's and I borrowed this from my you
know this is my ex boyfriends
girlfriends lipstick I found under his
bed I mean it just turns into such a
fascinating sort of litany of stories so
that's a question I find in New York
City you could always ask what color
nail polish the cashier is wearing
because often the cashiers in New York
City like it's like what's the one thing
I can do to make me unfit for this job
and it's like I'm gonna grow my nails so
long they're gonna curl under like to
basically do nothing and say they can
tend to be pretty rude you know but but
if you say anything about their nails
everything changes everything did you do
that yourself what color how often do
you get your nails done everything
changes so much pride yeah and it's it
takes so much work and I think you know
nails are something I never took
seriously and it's actually made me a
better writer when I put effort into my
nails because you're looking at your
hands all day that's all we ever look at
now so well right yeah so my nails are a
mess I always just my self-esteem is a
little bit lower I had a really good
idea for finger nails a while ago and
I'm trying to remember something too and
I'd something I've never seen anybody do
with their finger nails gosh darn it and
I can't remember rip them off
no it was he's going out his notepad
this is a big it was pretty good just
skipped a beat this is the infamous note
but ad just came out I'm dying you know
how much we could get for that on eBay
but I did have an idea for and I don't
know if this exists yet okay
Oh makeup company called apocalypse but
Li PS you know so it would be and then
you could do a tank right now called
shark tank guys and then you could do $8
and the eye makeup would be called
apocalypse brow get the money
I mean we're printing money in here but
telic don't call Mark Cuban at shark
tank
let's go a shark tank a show where
people put bright ideas and yes they
pitch ideas and then a bunch of
financers give them money start their
product well this uh no of this exists
either but I thought of a restaurant
called ramen holiday I had a pretty
ambitious I I wanted to do a weave store
for a long time and I worked on a lot of
like weave store ideas like Adam and
we've we've only ever I wanted to kind
of like leave it to Bieber would be
perfect for like people here in there
unbelievable unbelievable
we ain't saw no wrong weaving on a jet
plane it could be in the airport take it
or leave it is the best look most guys
have tried different ways to last longer
but saying the Pledge of Allegiance in
your head counting backwards from 10
doesn't always work maybe saying the
Pledge of Allegiance might give you a
boner actually maybe we should have said
some people America oh yeah folks at
Roman a men's health company are
changing the game with Roman swipes the
secret to longer-lasting sexuals Roman
swipes that are not clinically proven to
help you last longer and better
effective easy to use fast-acting but
they don't require a prescription they
will not trance
your partner so you can last longer
without worrying you got enough worries
when you're in there bumpin uglies
they're super easy to use too you just
take your swipe out of the packet you
swipe it on your little peepee
oh you let it dry and then you're good
to go that's all you got to do and
you've got a numb one get 10% off your
first order of swipes and free two-day
shipping at get roman comm slash Whitney
that's get Roman comm slash Whitney for
$10 off and free two-day shipping get
Roman dot-com slash quit net earnest do
you have student loans refinancing them
with earnest could save you money on
lower are you being so sad about this
because have you ever had a student loan
yes I have kept it on I know people
student loans need a more positive
attitude to get through it earnest do
you have student loans refinancing them
with earnest could save you money or
lower your monthly pain and it only
takes two minutes to check your AMA and
rate if you are still paying the same
rate you were paying when you graduated
odds are you can reduce your monthly
payment and save big big big even if you
have refinanced before with today's low
rate environment most people can save by
refinancing again if you qualify earnest
offers customizable loan terms and no
fees it's fast it's easy you just
complete a few questions online takes
like two minutes but you'll be able to
do because you have a college education
which is why you have loans in the first
place you're gonna get a personalized
estimate all without affecting your
credit score hashtag that's very
important you can even combine private
and federal loans sounds very
complicated but they'll do it plus the
internet loves Ernests customer service
they're rated nine point four out of ten
on Trustpilot so you'll always get the
support you need they're the best start
saving right now our listeners get $100
cash bonus when you refinance a student
loan at earnest calm / quit now that's a
hundred dollars cash bonus when you
refinance a student loan at earnest calm
/ Whitney go to earnest calm well you
know I've said it four times but go to
earnest calm / Whitney today terms and
conditions
it's my dream to open a company to just
like name stores and name restaurants
and stuff have you ever been to the
Philippines I haven't
the Philippines is really the world
capital of pond names for businesses I
love it
I didn't expect at all and one of the
Philippines and I laughed all day over
the names of stores and the Simpsons has
always been good at that too when they
go to a mall always the best
I love shops if you can get three puns
in one USA the USA Network does a good
job with this they have these shows that
will be called like you know blue collar
and it's about blue collar people you
know they there's a chef that
specializes in like making fish collar
or something and then it'll be in a blue
state and the guys name will be like
mister blue like they'll put so many
puns within one thing so I love coming
up with fake us a TV show titles um
there was something oh it was in my
diary oh gosh what was it and it was oh
gosh sorry alright just give me a second
it was oh I bought my sister Amy some
rabbit shaped candles for her Christmas
stocking and when I was in Berlin and
then I said to Hugh I said they're
pretty and everything but when you light
up they smell like burning hair right
and every time I've read that on stage
the audience groans and I don't think
that's an acceptable reaction to a pun
why do people groan I never grow is that
new is it do you notice it's no they've
always done it they've always people are
conditioned to think that that is the
acceptable response to a pun but I love
it don't think it was visualizing a dead
rabbit no no no no no they're just
groaning because it's a pun right it's
like yeah or more like that but I don't
know why is that the response to
wordplay I remember a friend of mine was
working at some company and they were I
don't know doing something with puns and
this one guy it always it still makes me
laugh and I hate myself that it makes me
laugh someone made a pun about the
Holocaust or something
and he goes I don't want to hear any
more puns about the Holocaust and
frankly I believe we should not ever
joke about that I think maybe it's just
because you know we work so hard to make
things sophisticated and complicated
sometimes the simplest little things
just tickle our brains I was in
Australia a few weeks ago and you know
the fires are going on it's all anyone's
talking about and I did a radio
interview and I had to listen to the
radio interview before me right and so
the woman said they've been talking
about fires all morning she said now
we're gonna put that aside I'm going to
pull out our crystal balls and we're
gonna look at the year column 2020 and
let's let's look into the future and
what do you think is gonna happen with
Bragg's in and what do you think is
gonna happen with Donald Trump and I'm
here to answer all your burning
questions and I don't think that she
meant to say that and so I was waiting
to go on and I was gonna say was all she
did I don't think she meant it and I was
gonna say well as a flaming homosexual I
often get burnt out on these tours the
fire but it was one of those things
where they're followed by traffic report
and then the weather report and by the
time you get back to it
it's all forgotten that she said burning
questions oh shit oh god that makes me
so happy I hate myself that I love it so
much it really tickled me
that in your master class you said one
of your big comedy inspirations was
Whoopi Goldberg
I saw Whoopi Goldberg's Broadway show on
a we had a videotape of it and I bet I
watched that thing no I don't know I
must have watched it 50 times and and
what was so great about it was she did
these characters but you would be
laughing and then the next second you
would be like like punched in the
stomach
yeah and she would just turn on a hair
and like and whenever people I don't
know I won't put up with any criticism
of Whoopi Goldberg none
Mathers time I met her went on the view
cried lost it I mean just loved her so
much start crying on air smiled she I
said something nice about her in the New
York Times and then this box of cookies
showed up I was in saw six it was hard I
don't know how she got my address and it
was shipped like immediately and then
she said if you're in New York let's go
out let's go out and have dinner and so
I was gonna be in New York for a few in
a few weeks and we went out to dinner
and I'm not good about meeting people
but she was so gracious that she took
all my nervousness away from me and was
just lovely but the waitress was from
Romania and I said to the waitress at
one point I said oh I just speak a
little Romania and I said but it's
filthy when I nod to say it's filthy but
she said say it and I said no that's
okay and she said say it and I said no
it's really bad and she said say it and
so I said it and what it is is I shit in
your mother's mouth and then the
waitress is like why would you say that
why would you say that to somebody and I
said we asked me and then Whoopi's like
wow what's going on with her cuz we was
talking you know somebody had come up to
you know say hello to her and she and
all of a sudden I've alienated the the
server at this restaurant but she was
that Broadway show that she did and it
really I've been writing for about I
don't know I'd been writing for like
probably seven years by the time that I
saw it but I was just writing in a diary
and I hadn't written really written
stories yet or essays or anything and it
really had a profound impact on me
because I I watch it and I thought
that's what I want I don't want to
perform I don't want to memorize
anything I'm not an actor I just want to
read out loud but I want to make people
feel like she made me feel mm-hmm she
also is so incredibly kind last time I
did her show she dragged me into her
dressing room and forced me to pick one
of her shoes
to take she collects these fantastic
shoes she has them made I'll show him
I'll show you I still have them there
like in a shrine in my closet and it was
like you're taking these you know she
just is like the kindest biggest hearted
person and also just the most
relentlessly authentic have you seen on
the view that she just farts whatever
she wants we pull this up oh she will
fart on the view and they'll dare it I
mean they don't even she doesn't even
care which one is this when Claire Danes
is on watch those stories that really
talk week our experience post 9/11 and
it's our identity was really questioned
and I think it explores that in a really
smart way
[Laughter]
I've never admitted to that I would have
acted like you know my chair made in a
bad mood I watch it I send it to people
that would ever like someone's going
through a breakup or divorce I just said
in that video I think a lot of people
maybe don't know about that
show that she did you know that Broadway
show that she did and it's what put her
on them on the map right I mean I also
think people forget she was a movie star
yeah I mean she was a be when I was a
Karam she was a movie star I mean those
Sister Act movies and I mean ghosts I
mean is that where the biggest movies of
all time yeah I think so God she was so
incredible that um I'm looking at your
notebook I'm sorry I just have to bring
it up this is a really big deal for me
to see your notebook are you ever
worried you're gonna lose it I've only
lost two but I think finding that nope
no I think most people wouldn't like I
collect grocery lists you know I find
them outside the grocery store I love
that but I don't I I think I'm the only
one who does you know I mean I don't
think other people collect them it's
probably if I lost my notebook nobody
would even think about it I don't know
that they'd look in here there I don't
know that they would you know would be
able to I'm always you know worried
because I my I am stupid and I send
emails to myself as my own notes but you
know I also have all these groups email
threads like you know whitney podcast
producers and then i'll sometimes write
all of these sort of little nuggets of
jokes and then send it off and I'm like
where are those and I realize I've sent
it to like my lawyer it's like it's just
bullet points that are like herpes
see IUD freeze eggs next week it's like
my to-do list is egg next that's really
good because sometimes people say will
you sign my diary and then I always make
their to-do list you know and it's like
get an abortion freeze eggs freeze eggs
really good eggs eggs don't be a
deadbeat mom
I remember Janeane Garofalo was on stage
a couple years ago and she she was like
I just lost my journal so if you see
anyone bombing in st. Louis tell em I
want my notebook you only do your sort
of entries you write them out you don't
ever do anything in computer mm-hmm
these little notes a little note and
then every morning I write my diary
uh-huh oh and so I pull out yeah and I
pull out my notebook and I and I look at
my I usually think like at what moment
yesterday that I feel the most alive and
then I start there and then I go through
all my notes and you know sometimes it's
things in the news or it's you know like
[Music]
like Kirk Douglas died the other day you
know so I put that in my diary yeah but
it was like number seven the thing in my
diary but but I always I don't know can
I ask how it works you wake up you make
a coffee or a tea do you look at the
news online sometimes I read the
newspaper in the morning in bed but then
I just get up and I go to my desk and
I'm you know I drink coffee and I sit on
my desk and and we start by writing in
my diary and then I turn to whatever
else it is that I'm working on mm-hmm
and how is your digital hygiene do you
have a phone do you get on the phone I
know I have a relationship with the
telephone Wow
I mean I I do things on my laptop you
know I have an iPad there aren't a bunch
of distractions it seems like I'm sure I
mean like with anybody you know I can
Google something or look at a website
but I I don't know I don't go overboard
with that like I seem to act like there
are 10 websites like I don't yeah like
and like with YouTube I look at
something on YouTube and then I'll
forget it exists for like five months I
just completely forget that it exists
but I don't I don't know I don't have a
lot of time to do that what websites do
you go to uh you know like the New York
Times or The Washington Post or that's
that what's it called it's it's these
men who criticize what people are
wearing calm and Lorenza oh yeah yeah
and I don't always agree with them
because sometimes they're like oh his
his jacket should be like a quarter of
an inch higher and I'm like really
that's what you're that and I don't
agree with them a lot but I like to see
what people are wearing I suppose there
was a website called the Satori Allah I
can't believe I've literally was about
to say that but I was too worried I was
gonna mispronounce it but I feel like a
lot of times what the people are wearing
is their beauty and so I don't think
that's quite fair well I think that's
such great website because it's kind of
just people in the wild that nailed it
you know just like really chic people in
different parts of the world and just
when you're like oh yeah you can wear
like white pants and a white shirt
everyone looks so effortless and sexy
but I was surprised the only time I've
ever commented on the computer it was
this Italian guy and he was and and he
was wearing a sweater like a green
sweater and he was wearing a pair of
culottes from comme des Garcons and he
was wearing a a collar that comme des
Garcons made that you it was like a
patent leather collar like a babydoll
collar then he had around his neck and
and all these people were because
usually they're really friendly on that
website and they were all wagons on him
and what's that things got around his
neck and I wrote I wrote and I used my
actual name because I didn't know and I
don't know anything to be ashamed of and
I said oh that's attached about collared
by coming us on and I couldn't believe
that nobody knew what it was
and
I thought maybe you people don't know as
much as I always thought you did but now
I think it's just a Instagram thing yeah
yeah that's too bad
do you go on Instagram yeah we know and
then I forget about it mm-hm you know I
forget that it exists there's a guy
named William cult mm-hmm see ult yeah
and he's British and he he posts things
that really they can be funny and
they're disturbing but they really make
you think I like him a lot that's nice
but you don't have your own page on
there like I do but I've never looked at
it that's interesting I don't think I
don't have anything to do with it I love
that what you say about your diary is to
always keep a diary in case you need to
go back and check people basically so
you can win arguments yeah it's really
good for that nightmare for you well for
Hugh because he doesn't it was
interesting because I pointed out lately
I mean we had a discussion argument a
while ago
and I was able to go back in my diary
and see that he had been on this kind of
jag we're like good two months you know
it wasn't just you got the receipts yeah
but to look back and se because he only
writes in his diary when he's depressed
and then he'll say I've been happy for a
long time and it's like because you only
write when you're miserable and that's
what you're looking at you know I also
love I'm you said somewhere that you
never bicker in public I try not to
that's such a good like relationship
lifehack well we may I mean we're not
always perfect for that but there been a
couple of times that we've really I mean
they're worse people but yeah that just
makes everybody really uncomfortable
mm-hmm so sometimes you just need to eat
it and then just wait till the company
leaves right and then you can have it
out but never in front of people do you
get sick of asking or hearing people ask
you why you haven't gotten married no I
don't know you know what I think
ah I think the thing is that I met so
many gay people who would say and this
is my husband Bradley and I thought I'd
always thought I don't want to be that I
don't want to sound like that get
married I really it really resonated
with me and in your master class it
sounds like they're paying me they're
not I truly watched it and loved it and
literally took notes um when you said
that people would come up to you and say
like wow you really hate your family
yeah I get that too when you're like no
I like you know it's just it that was
such a fascinating thing just about
navigating how to write about your
family in there but I think so many
people I mean it's interesting to hear
people on the phone and you don't hear
them on the phone way you used to
because now people text and everything
okay but on the phone everyone say I
love you I love you I love you and then
they'd be on the plane before you take
off and they're calling everyone and
telling saying I love you in case the
plane crashes I guess and but that's the
way they think that if you don't say I
love them so and so then you don't love
them but I read somewhere it was the
other day was something in the newspaper
it was an op-ed in the New York Times
and I don't remember who it was by but
it was this one was talking about I love
you I love you and the guy said look I
said it to you thirty years ago when we
got married and if anything changes I'll
let you know goes without saying which I
mean to me it's completely the opposite
I usually say I love you when I've done
something super shitty to try to fix it
like you know I love you right like can
we erase every all the shitty behavior
gosh I can't you know in the last time I
told anybody that I love them I really
can't
I don't you should just show it instead
of yeah I feel like it I don't feel like
I have to you know you can say it in
other ways gifts you know yeah or yeah I
mean money I'll write it you know the
writer George Saunders
I really have so much respect for him
and he's such a great writer
and we were emailing each other about a
project and he wrote back love and I
thought wow that's really great for a
man to write to another man love and I
thought I'm gonna start doing that too
so do it all the time like to you know
if you're sending back an email to
somebody to say love at the end of it
and so okay I'll say I love you that way
you know it's in the end of an email but
I'm not gonna say like I love you and
here don't say I love you mmm no
sometimes I'll say do you love me yes
but it's more of a jokey thing you know
that's such a trap of a question yeah
there's no way you can answer that
without getting in trouble I do more
often is do you remember when you loved
me I said that a lot how long has it
been 30 years wolf what's your biggest
piece of relationship advice never say I
love you
talk about your relationship oh that's
that way I'm single again that way lies
madness never talked about your
relationship either privately or to a
therapist never do it Wow yeah
incredible advice don't gossip about
your partner basically oh no no you can
gossip Bob no you can talk about it
other people yeah you just don't talk
about to that person oh yeah yeah no no
no no you tell other people everything
and I said that to you I said I want you
to talk shit about me - Manuela and to
your other friends you need that you
know you need that you can say whatever
you want about me but you and I are
never going to talk about this really
cuz it's just masturbatory or nothing
ever it just it's it's the beginning of
the end
it is basically don't go to the problem
for the solution yeah
don't and then I mean we'll joke about
it and I'll say can we go to lunch just
the two of us I want to talk about a
relationship but I'm just kidding
that's so wild when did you discover
that with my with my last boyfriend Wow
yeah I realized because you're never
gonna I'm sorry but I don't I don't know
that you were ever gonna change somebody
or you ever gonna necessarily fix
something if some of these terrible and
they make you feel awful all the time
you should probably leave but I'm just
so grateful you know I will put up with
anything I mean pretty much because I
just don't want to be single and I don't
wanna have to look for somebody else and
I don't have to break somebody else in
and catch them up on everything yeah and
I don't you always say to Hue like
somebody's got to stay together why not
us I mean that's a good enough reason to
stay together because someone's got to
do it
[Laughter]
I it blew my mind although I'm so you
know I know this is gonna have people so
much hope but that you said in them in
your class that you wrote every day for
15 years before your first book got
published mm-hmm
that is just so wild really it seemed
perfectly normal to me I mean that
seemed what you would do like you you
know you start writing and you stink
and you think well of course I stink
I've only been doing it for three days
and then I've only been doing it for
three years and I've only been doing it
for 13 years but I don't know I didn't
put a timer on myself
did you put a timer on yourself via
career Hollywood probably did but I
don't know if I did I had a really lucky
thing happen where I just in a 42 astern
I happen to be somewhere with that's
kind of a weird story
I happen to be backstage with a very
famous comedian who said to me you can
never make it too late hmm just said it
to me at the exact time I needed to hear
it and it was just like don't rush this
this is the one thing that you know you
you're just gonna get better every day
and that was really helpful you know I
think I just need I think I needed to
hear that as a comedian you can never
make it too late opposed to being like a
actress or something you have to make it
really young so I then got really sort
of paranoid about making it too early
and not being cooked enough because
someone else said to me you can never
take back the first time people see you
in the first impression you've owned
them does that make any exam yeah you
know I always think that like you know
I'm going on this tour right in the
spring and so I have three new stories
so far and you can only read something
first one time right so when you go out
on stage do you think is this the
audience because if you read it on stage
and nobody responds me I'm gonna say
this sucks so I'm never gonna read this
again right um
so you have to be careful um you have to
be careful where you try something yeah
but yeah that that it I'm always puzzled
by that especially because like you said
if if you're like a model right and you
say well you know I'm 75 you know maybe
it's time to hang up that dream you know
but if you're a writer
there's my agra commercials there's
plenty of things yeah older models to do
these days but if you're a writer um
then you you know what I'm surprised by
and and this is just something I've
noticed and it it's so interesting to me
people who ok people probably told you
at a young age they said you're funny
okay did they not I'm the only problem
with me as I wasn't trying to be funny I
was trying to be serious uh-huh and then
I ended up being funny so that it wasn't
exactly what I was fishing for but it it
eventually got to me yeah because I just
seemed to know
some people lately and and they've
decided like in late middle age I'm
gonna go do improv I'm gonna start doing
stand-up just like no one ever told them
they were funny and that would be like
if you just decided I'm gonna become a
model and no one ever said to you are
you a model
or you should be a model I just think
it's something people would have said -
yes yes you have to have some kind of
encouragement or it has to pique your
yeah and I also kind of got weirdly
lucky because my and I don't know why
this is the case I think it was just
this was back when blockbuster was big
and I would get like a blockbuster movie
and we never were there was a couple
blockbuster movies we just never
returned because we couldn't afford to
pay the fee or whatever and we'd watch
the same ones over and over again and
one of my heroes was Rodney Dangerfield
and I just loved him and but he was one
of the only comedians I had a lot of
exposure to as a kid but I remember
hearing somewhere that he made it when
he was like 55 or something and now does
always stuck with me you know it's it's
nice how things like that can give you
hope I mean can give so many people hope
the fact that somebody you know made it
later on in life then you can think okay
I'm not because I just meet a lot of
people at readings and I'm like calm
down you know calm down you're 24 yeah
no one gets a book published when
they're 24 you know you're doing exactly
what you should be doing yeah you're
just working and failing and learning
from it and trying something else
don't leave the rest of it up to other
people yeah and just go get interesting
I think is what you know I remember Gary
Shandling saying to me just like you're
only gonna get more interesting you know
and that your material is a comedian at
that age is kind of gonna be like your
style or your haircut at that age you're
gonna look back and be like oh god what
was I thinking which I kind of loved I
just needed to hear that I think well I
what my fear always in writing is to
look like I'm trying and so when I look
back on early stuff I just see somebody
who's trying too hard
you know and that kind of changed when I
started reading out loud a lot because
then you proves you can get a laugh and
then you say okay now what would be like
to not get the laugh wasn't so
fascinating and you said it was your dad
that said don't force it
he says don't force it like don't force
it like don't try to force that cup into
the dishwasher
don't try to so he meant it like that
for sad joke well I just I think in in
performing you know stand up especially
the harder you try the less power you
have as soon as they start to sniff out
any desperation they recoil and they
know that they have the power it's some
like human nature thing see I can't
imagine doing stand-up I can't imagine
having what it takes to do that no
because I like to read out loud and that
paper makes all the difference in the
world that piece of paper yeah no one
has ever heckled me because I have a
piece of paper in my hand huh and I
would tie on and I'm standing at a
podium and you know people just respect
you they just don't respect me oh I know
I think it makes all the difference
there's a reverence I think for you know
I don't know like when I first oh no I
don't think that I don't think it's that
I think it's just a piece of paper I
think it's simply a piece of paper but
there also could be some training of you
hearing you on NPR for so long you know
no one was allowed to yell back at you
like when I hear you I get really quiet
but I'm like you know I listen you
before you could even rewind it was like
if you shut up everyone shut up he's
talking you know if you interrupt you're
gonna miss it so I think there's a
little bit of a Pavlovian reaction when
I hear you talk even now I'm like so
afraid to know have you ever wanted to
try standup no the closest I get is when
I go on tour there's a
question-and-answer at the end at the
end and sometimes people are slow to
answer to offer questions and so I start
doing stick alright just you know I'll
talk about something that happened
earlier in the tour and then you know
how that
is he new tell the story and then you
think gosh it works even better when I
add this to it and then so over the
course of the tour I'll develop a couple
minutes worth of stay and it's never
anything I would write mm-hmm you know I
mean like it's not writing it down would
make it a whole different thing
and it's not necessarily even worthy of
being written down but I'm always a
little bit embarrassed because I think
if somebody come to the show the night
before they'd be like wait a minute
that's what he said I mean that would be
hard I think is a comedian if somebody
films your act and I'll see it and then
they see you it's like oh I've heard
that joke already yeah yeah I mean it is
really the great nightmare I think for
for comedians that you know someone sees
the same thing twice but at the same
time it is you know is part of it you
know I think it's not like music where
people want to hear the hits you know
people want to hear the thing they've
never heard or be surprised which is why
now we kind of have to do those bags you
know when you go home a stand-up show
now you have to put your cell phone in a
bag so people don't record and put on
the internet you know because we have to
try so hard to keep it a surprise but if
I and if I'm on a tour and I meet
somebody let's say I'm in Lawrence
Kansas and they say I'm coming to see
you again next week in st. Louis I'll
make a note of it and so I don't repeat
myself because and I wound up doing the
entire show from one person for one
person in the audience because I don't
want to repeat myself to that person oh
that is so wild Bolger will fresh bombs
off that sounds good
Bonjour fresh mouth-watering seasonal
recipes and pre measured ingredients
delivered right to your dough with hell
of fresh America's number one meal kit
hello fresh makes cooking at home fun
easy and affordable and you know this
get out of that rut with hella fresh is
22 season and plus there's more than 22
but there's 22 plus I love those bra
size I got confused
something for everyone wouldn't YouTube
hello fresh I do I I'm doing the calorie
counter one right now it has a guy very
fun I've had butternut squash chicken
ah everything's been great very easy
very very easy it's already
pre-portioned so there's no like prep
and you just throw it all together and
all of a sudden you're a chef out of
nowhere
everyone I know does this yeah I mean
it's really super simple they give us I
thought you were gonna say more you love
this company so the same you're always
telling me about your goddamn hell of a
fresh meal now you have nothing to say
all of a sudden now you're quiet
he's always talking about these freaking
fresh meals now now all of a sudden you
made of Helen Keller over here go to
hello fresh calm slash one zero good and
use the code one zero good for ten free
meals including free shipping we're very
confused by this code but we love this
company hello fresh com / 1-0 good use
the code 1-0 good for 10 free meals that
are good it includes free shipping who
picks the code huh
you know what really bothers me when I
see someone's dog and I'm like what kind
of dog is that and they're like I don't
know it's a mix like bitch
mutt I want to know exactly what kind of
dog it is you know what if you want one
get that I tell them get there's an
intestine bark and you sent a swab of
spit so I don't have to keep wondering
what kind of dog you have really bothers
me it's funny you bring them up the
response what you know whether you have
a new pup or an old friend and embark
breed and health test is the key to
unlocking your dog's unique breed mix
and genetically informed health needs
I'm just gonna say this my own words I
don't really need to read it you have to
get genetic testing for your freaking
dog that way you can find out what
they're predisposed for skin problems
stomach problems joint problems what are
you doing yeah anyone know what their
history where they want to know what
they're bred for you want to know why
they keep you know trying to eat your
panties maybe it's a certain debris
thing who knows figure out your dog's
breed you improve their quality of life
because you know what they're
predisposed for you can tell your vet oh
this dog is you know half
you know Staffie half German Shepherd
half Pomeranian cat yeah whatever
and then they can go
oh great your dogs predisposed to this -
saves you money in the long run and your
dogs gonna live longer if you know the
crap that they need I wish I knew right
away what Frank was I wish I'd known he
was a Great Dane yeah
that I would have known he's not grown
the living I know that a donkey growing
in my garage right now embark has an
exclusive offer you can't get anywhere
else go to embark vet comm now use the
promo code Cummings to save 15% off your
dog DNA test get visit embark vet calm
and use promo code Cummings to sing I
have a couple questions that were sent
in from the OL internet don't really I
have one question that's from Justin
Theroux oh yeah do you know Justin yes I
do
his question and he's so funny he is so
funny and it makes me angry and I really
love how - how he can do any acts he's a
friend of my sisters yeah and how he can
just do any act he's loved life at the
party they're always so funny so quick
it makes me jealous and kind of angry
sometimes it doesn't seem fair that yeah
that's right all right like really act
and he can be that person as well and
he's like a dog person and he's it's
it's it's very frustrating but he has a
question for you which is I would like
to know why you don't invite me on trips
to Tokyo oh gosh shopping trips yeah oh
we would love to have him we see we
couldn't go he couldn't Amy couldn't
come with us this last January we call
it Japan you arey yeah and so we go
every Japan you arey because she was
filming her show yeah but we rent a
house a whole house so gosh I'd love
that it's out young sometimes yeah he's
because you need a guide when you go to
Tokyo for the first time mm-hmm and if
like I know people who have said oh can
I go to Tokyo with you and it's like
what are you interested in buying and
they say no I just want to see temple
don't come with me because he you like I
don't know probably I don't know 14
years ago I said
this is the last temple I'm ever going
to and I've never been to another one I
all I care about him something yep yeah
when Justin he and was he's a great
dresser I loved taking him around on
bull shuttles and what is your number
one item you'll go for clothes uh yeah
clothes and pottery I don't know what's
going on with me I really don't like I
don't like clothing wise okay I bought a
jacket a couple days ago in it and it's
a black wool but not heavy wool right
like maybe I just looks like material to
me and in it and it's like a jacket a
sport coat but then found under it come
layers of ruffles like just layers and
layers and and any you can't get blacker
than black but this seems to be
something that somebody in Gone with the
Wind would wear when they're in deep
deep mourning and I and I don't know
that it's for me don't I mean I can't
not buy it buy it and it must weigh 15
pounds love it
and so it's too heavy to travel with but
I was with a me and I said I can wear it
to dad's funeral and she said that's
like that's like the tenth jacket you've
went to wear to wear to death changes
full Oscar host I'm gonna have so many
changes at my dad's funeral you ship
stuff back you go to Tokyo and ship
stuff home uh well we ship things one
time and things didn't come so now I
just try to carry it but this time I
went to Tokyo and then I went to Hong
Kong and then I went to Australia for a
tour
so I shipped things home from Australia
mmm it must be impossible to buy a gift
for you no I don't think so but you know
one thing that's nice about like Hugh
and I are back and we got a place in New
York and I wouldn't say we've moved back
to New York we just have a place there
now and you walk around it's empty
storefront empty storefront empty
storefront in Tokyo I have never seen in
a storefront and you can go anywhere to
the far edge of town and get off of the
subway and there are these towers and
the subway station and there their
towers and their stores in the towers
right like like a boutique for this a
boutique for this person and in it's
packed yeah when you go there on a
weekday and and you think how are so
many people in this building and that's
just one at the far edge of town and
it's like that all over and it's really
really beautiful to see people I don't
know they don't buy things online yeah
and they their apartments are small and
so they get rid of stuff and they buy
new stuff and they're just constantly
buying stuff and I'm all for it it's so
hard for me to get out of my head and
it's so hard for me to when I'm you know
which I related so much in your in your
class because I'm just always when I'm
talking something I'm I was like how is
this a joke how is this something how is
this a scene is we to even do with
Twitter now I'm like should I tweet
about this should I post this it's so
hard for me to be present and the last
time I felt like I was truly in awe and
completely present was in Tokyo at the
robot restaurant
this might be too lowbrow for you have
you ever been no can you pull up the
robot restaurant it is a show in Tokyo I
mean even watching the videos on YouTube
is fun and it is all of these like giant
sparkly dinosaurs and pandas and lights
I mean it is the most wild experience I
have ever had in person you go inside
ooh and I mean everything's mirrored and
the lights are crazy but fast forward to
the show I'm gonna see the robot right
on the show all these robots start
fighting each other it's so cool
this goes on for like two and a half
hours well it's the wildest thing I've
truly ever seen in person
it's the only thing that's ever made me
want to put my phone down and be present
we you know it's always so interesting
to me that you know when you live in the
United States and you hear this is the
greatest city on earth it's like you
need to get out more often you know
there's a lot of competition for
greatest city on earth out there right
you know right I was in Sweden recently
and Swedes not everyone is like this in
the world but Swedes are raised to
believe that they live in the best
country on earth and that they're the
best health care and they have the best
this and that and it's interesting to go
to another country and realize that
they're told the same that's such thing
that you're told but I think so many
people and it's just you know and I
understand it you know it's expensive to
travel but they really need to get out a
little bit more yeah what is your
favorite city to visit Tokyo yeah second
favorite uh I like well I like all of
Germany mm-hmm I take pretty much you
can go to Mannheim Germany and still
spend $400 on postcards oh wow Germany
is is the the world capital of really
good postcards really when I say good
postcards
I mean joke postcards like cartoons on a
postcard and it's all in German so I
don't understand it but it doesn't
matter you know like I this is one that
I got and it's all these nudists eating
hot dogs and outdoor cookout and I don't
know I don't know what it's about but
the drawing is fantastic
and I and there sometimes you go like if
you go to the Art Institute of Chicago
and took my postcard
it's like they're printing them on
receipt paper now you know there's so
they're not good to send but they're a
good thickness and I'm
always happy to buy a postcard because I
I send so many and I go through them
alot those birds were like the first
meme you know it was the first like joke
in a square I feel like that we had you
know now they do an Instagram you have
like a little meme that's like a little
joke that's really what a postcard was
well like even New York or like if New
Yorker postcard New Yorker cartoons were
postcards
if I were especially if I were not
American
I'd buy those by the thousands yeah
because I cuz they're pretty and you
don't understand what they mean I look
for a man
another question I got for you are you
religious and do you pray absolutely not
absolutely not I'm not and even I am NOT
spiritual you're not spiritual I'm not
spare sure and when people ya know I'm
not any of that
even when see even when shit hits the
fan are you a person if something goes
wrong you start going hey God just
checking in I went to a doctor a year
ago and he said you have cancer and I
did not say anything to God interest I
don't have cancer and that maybe that
made it easier diagnosis yeah I mean I
felt you know I did feel kind of sorry
for myself God was on her mind he's not
gonna check it well all I ever asked is
that my cancer be above the waist that's
all I ever asked right because I don't
want people imagining like wouldn't it
be awful to have rectal cancer and then
you're embarrassed to tell people what
kind of cancer you have and it's as if
to add insult in you you not have to
think about my cancer is right yeah yeah
because then people are gonna imagine
what kind of plumbing thing is going on
and and then it's so unfair that you
have cancer and then you don't get any
of the benefits no none no one feels
sorry for you they're just grossed out
by you so this was bladder cancer right
and so I thought I'd make
myself a new one out of one of those
goatskin sacks you know that people who
drink out of when they go to Greece you
know when they're a teenager yeah yeah
yeah I don't know why you can't make a
bladder out of a goatskin sack I'm sure
I mean but it turns out I'm okay and he
was the doctor was wrong
he was just wrong but what's crazy is he
led with that while I said I will let
your own area tract infection and in his
blood in my urine he said we probably
have cancer this you have bladder cancer
yeah your bladder cancer or you have
prostate cancer and then and then come
back in like three days and we'll run
some tests and then I'm back on the
street and everyone's waiting for that
day and I thought wow I didn't know
today was gonna be that day but it
wasn't red hair I'm never gonna go see a
redheaded doctor again I actually I have
so much compassion for redheads because
when I went and froze my eggs
I started looking at sperm donors and I
got really into these sperm donor sites
and I found out that maybe it's just
certain companies but these sperm banks
don't accept sperm from redheads really
it just broke my heart and no that's not
I mean I would label it you know I'd
label it Viking scotch-irish sperm from
redheads heartbreaking they'd like don't
even bother awful upset me that really
is you imagine going to try to donate
sperm you know try and help a woman but
plus you know I think maybe people are
if you put Prince Harry on the label any
prints that the different undoes the
redhead yeah but he's a good-looking guy
yes you know he's a really good-looking
redheads strapping yeah yes so maybe
people are thinking other redheads you
know maybe they're just not enough
positive representation that's true it's
like a royal redheads is a different
kind of deal
I would say isn't that sad that really
upset me that made me want to just go
you know buy some redhead sperm just to
feel better someone really wants to know
how you quit smoking I told myself that
I was allotted a certain number of
cigarettes at birth and then I went
through them all huh and if I'd smoked
more slowly I would still be smoking but
I insisted on smoking two packs a day
so I went through them all and that's it
I can't and I did the same with alcohol
Wow like there are rooms full of alcohol
you know like beakers that would be like
the size of this room and they were like
five allotted to me and I emptied all
five and it's like sorry you finish it
all
and it really helped that's incredible
most people who quit smoking quit like
many times before that's and they have a
history of failure right but I never
tried to quit so I had no history of
failure so I think that made it easier
as well hmm that's really intense
someone really wants to know when you
were a judge on RuPaul's Drag Race was
it scary no everybody who worked on that
show with lovely every single every
single person on that show was lovely
and they made you feel so welcome and I
didn't want to say anything bad about
anybody because this is their dream
right and they don't know who I am and
so Who am I to get up there and shit on
their dream but they didn't make me say
anything bad you know I just said good
things about the people I liked and and
they were all fine with that and it was
you know as a big fan of the show so I'd
seen every episode not just once I'd
seen that for every episode many times
and yeah everybody and then I ran into
RuPaul or come months ago in London and
it was a freeze Art Fair and I had
tickets to go to one part of it and
there are two parts of it and I didn't
want to bother him right I didn't expect
he would remember me so just with a
friend and I was just quietly he said
David Sedaris where do you think you're
going and it was so nice and I said well
I'm going to this one I don't have
tickets for this and he said we'll come
with us you know we have we'll get you
in and he had like some super VIP you
know how that is you're thinking okay
when we get in there what's gonna happen
do I and we got in and he said okay kids
you're on your own and I thought that is
the perfect way to handle that yeah he
really has he's really just you know a
really lovely person and I I always just
think it's so great when someone is
completely themselves and and the world
says great we we really especially when
you wouldn't have expected it like in
your youth you wouldn't have expected
that someone like him who's being
completely himself the world would fall
for and I can see how that really gives
hope to so many people not necessarily
drag queens but just you know anybody
who who you know you can always spot a
phony you know like yeah and and and
it's like you responded in writing to
when somebody's like taking a political
position that you think that's not
really yeah you know you're just trying
to please me or you're just trying to
you can always always tell when
somebody's not being honest that way and
I never spotted a moment of that in
RuPaul and there's also something about
seeing RuPaul in the world
it's like seeing a giraffe I mean
there's times that I've seen him walking
into something and there's it's just
it's like he's in his zone he floats
down the street I remember one time my
son walking into a dinner party with he
was in all white and a bright ruby red
back and it just was like you're just
such on a such a different level like
this divine floaty
deity into a party you know it's very
intimidating to just run into RuPaul
well like I said I didn't expect him to
remember me and so I didn't want to I
don't know I didn't want to hold him up
or anything and that was so kind of him
you know you know another person is kind
and I just always I think about this all
the time
I'm not comfortable on TV you know
really I feel like I was so good on talk
shows no it's not doesn't come natural
to me
but I did Jimmy Fallon mhm and Reese
Witherspoon was on she was the main
guest and I always take my friend and
these daughters on TV when I go I've
known him since they were born and I
always bring with me
and at the time the girls were like 12
and 13 years old and Reese Witherspoon
came to my dressing room with a bowl of
nuts
we all had a bowl of nuts in our room
but she acted like these were a present
for me and then she and she saw the
girls and she said girls do you think we
could get a picture together and the
girls never would have asked ah and that
was such a classy thing so do ya I
always think of that she didn't have to
do that she didn't have to and she
didn't wait for that they again they
would not have asked and it was just
such a classy thing to do that is such a
cool thing to just get ahead of it
because they would never yeah oh that is
just so cool I even tried to now take
someone's phone because I think
sometimes you see someone all of a
sudden when they come to take a picture
they don't know how used to use their
phone all of a sudden I just grab it and
just take it so that I know it's gonna
be good Lighting's gonna be good and you
know how do you react when people want
to take photos of you I don't like
having my picture taken and it bothers
me when people take your picture like
you're a statue you know like they don't
ask you or anything yeah that kind of
bothers me it just seems really rude to
me right so if somebody comes up and
says can we get a picture I say oh I'll
draw our picture and I'll pull out my
notebook and I'll say I'd draw a picture
of us together and I'm happy to talk to
people but I just I just don't
understand what the picture means yeah
you know like proof that they saw you
they want proof yeah but I'm just so
interesting someone was like do you
think someone's gonna think you're lying
right if if you say you saw me why do
you need the proof or you have just
liar normally well like I had heard that
Kevin Hart when he went on his book tour
he took pictures with people but he just
stocks selling books right and then took
pictures with people and I guess that's
what people wanted then they could get a
picture of themselves with Haven or put
it on their Instagram account but I
don't know I'd rather talk to people and
I'd rather I'd rather do it that way you
know very famous comedian I know used to
say you know I won't take a picture with
you but I will talk to you for five
minutes and not one person ever took him
up on it
Wow that's interesting
sometimes people get really mad when you
don't want your picture taken and and
and then I don't you know it's like when
somebody comes up to get a book starring
and they say I want you to write keep
laughing and I say you know what boy in
the book because it makes it sound like
I think I'm funny yeah and I wouldn't I
wouldn't I just wouldn't do that
that's so a lot of people ask me like
can you flick off the camera I'm like no
why are you making me look like an
asshole now I look why are you making me
a jerk in this photo well I'm sorry but
also you're the professional
yeah I got in to me like you're the
funny person and the relationship they
came and paid to see you
right so you know and so okay let's say
you say to me will you write keep
laughing okay and I'll say no I won't
but I'm like I'm happy to draw a picture
I'm gonna say you know what actually I'm
gonna draw your sister don't you and
they say yeah I have a sister and I say
I'm just gonna draw circle your sister
[Laughter]
but I mean I mean in a really good way
my sister doesn't shave that is most
horrified
it's very perky tits though and great
nipples I mean I would love cankles the
cankles are a little rough cowboy boots
can you believe
with the art school yes I can this is so
like like genius
oh no she had a knee injury she had a
bad knee injury it's a sports injury
torn ACL oh but she had some vaginal
rejuvenation I think and then one of
these are they just floating nipples no
that was just that was I don't know just
that's nothing we were talking earlier
and I just can I keep this and so of
course last couple of questions I know
do you have to leave tonight no no I'm
here to do I'm going on television
tomorrow
what show Jimmy Fallon I'm Jimmy Kimmel
who's a lovely person is the best 11 and
then iiiii show got cancelled because
the weather's in Northern California so
have to go make that up but then I'm
just gonna do a show in Vancouver and
then go back then I'm going to Argentina
oh nice for a vacation
oh are you good at vacationing like good
at taking the time I mean I'll work
every day yeah on vacation but I'm going
with a really old friend of mine so how
many days uh we're gonna go for a week
but we're gonna go to Argentina now this
is a hard thing okay ch i le g la right
she only sound like an asshole when you
say Chile Chile Chile it's not chilly
right you're an asshole if you say
you're trash if you say that and if you
see chill a your election icing right so
I'm going to our Ken Venus chill a
tambien Hey org why this place wow
that's sexy he always goes sexy when in
doubt just be sexual and then I took
Spanish in high school and I'm boning up
on MySpace oh excuse me excuse me sir in
this climate you're gonna talk to me
like that I'm I'm and I remember a lot
of words but I'm trying to refresh
myself on my verb agreement and things
like that but you know that's been
that's a really great conversational
starter to like this morning there was a
fellow in my restaurant
said I said do you speak Spanish and he
said yes and I said how do I say I'm
looking because I remembered I'm looking
for my friend and is this how I say it
and he said no you say it like this and
but it's great yeah because it's it's a
really everyone's happy to do that
everyone's happy to impart their
knowledge I think yeah I think so too
and are you listening to tapes or some
kind of yeah refresh your typing which
one Pimsleur but it's interesting
because I've used Pimsleur whenever I go
anywhere like so I went to Sweden uh-huh
and I studied Swedish for a month really
and Romania instead remain anyways just
for a month but in Romania our driver
dropped us off at our hotel and said
it's a pedestrian street it's just up
the next block well it was actually a
mile away but my Pimsleur let me said do
you know where the someone's a hotel and
when they said go straight and turn left
I knew what they were saying because I
rights and so I used it for a visa for
Japanese and for Polish and for Wow
German and it's German the hardest to
learn you're American
I don't think so I mean if you speak
other languages then you kind of get an
idea like if you don't speak another
language and like wait a minute that
noun has a gender you know but if you
speak other languages you're you you
know you've already got that part down
but what does that have anything to do
with you asked if you're o Arjun Tim's
ler yes right but I've noticed like with
because I've used it for so many
languages and usually it follows the
same pattern but the Spanish is like I'm
sick my mother and I are sick my entire
family is sales are always you know a
doctor do you know a good doctor and
they took your master class asking good
question but they're just but the other
language is no one says I never learned
I'm sick and Swedish because they have
great health care well I guess like
you'll never have to ask this but you're
just expected to get to drink
contaminated
they're in a country that where you
speak Spanish yeah they're basic like
Montezuma's Revenge yes how do I deal
with the fact that I can't stop shitting
is like the first question they teach
you yeah it was just really interesting
well it it really is interesting because
I beat the German one was meaner than
others really and it's like like you I
learned to say I don't understand you
why I don't understand you and then you
say why because you don't speak German
like they know none of the other
languages are that confrontational yeah
but the German was like you're arguing
at the waiter Janice like that's not
right you still owe me like 15 euros and
but they didn't you know in Japanese you
never argue no no no that's so funny but
also the Spanish I think was done
recently is it the only one that has
taught me the word email the other ones
are like do you have a telephone book oh
wow I really need a fax machine yeah
yeah oh that's wild
that is so telling but in the country
like you know if you go to Romania like
I was in Serbia recently Wow
and I said who are your immigrants and
they're like nobody you know like nobody
comes here no Syrians you know Syrian
refugees like a Syrian refugee wound up
in Bucharest and then he thought he was
had made it to Austria and they said no
you're in Romania and he cried they put
his shoes back on and he had walked like
800 miles from Aleppo and so you go to a
lot of these countries in Eastern Europe
and and everybody's white because nobody
wants to immigrate there what Serbia
like I saw a banner with pictures of
young men on it and it was and I said I
said where they killed in the war and
the driver are hired said no
oh they is all kidnapped by Albanians
who steal parts like maybe some
alcoholic need a liver
maybe somebody somewhere need a kidney
and so I said oh I said their organs
were harvested so I'm like giving
someone in English lesson
you know it's but but that's the phrase
you're teaching them their organs work
every student in America we know we have
a word for this oh why are there a
billboard cuz they were missing no
because they were killed kidnapped and
then their organs were harvested and
they died and said they would just put
on billboard just thank you for your
service sir uh no it was just like oh
this is sad oh god yeah
Oh bummer and then I went to Bosnia
welcome to Serbia and Bosnia liver lists
children to a hotel that was out in the
countryside and it was like a village of
yesteryear right so they had farm
animals wandering around and but they
had like artificial streams and then
they had you know those bridges that are
like half a circle ya know that go high
over the water that were covered with
moss and wet leaves and they had no
handrails no it's my friend Patsy fell
into ass slid down but you can tell when
you're in a country that doesn't have a
word for lawsuits oh and also it's
interesting to go to a restaurant in
2020 and the all of the eight people
next to you at breakfast are smoking oh
because we're just so not used to saying
that anymore or when someone doesn't
even ask if you want us non-smoking room
right like they don't have any
non-smoking rooms I think I was in I
want to say Kentucky last year
performing and someone was smoking
inside and it was such a trip to see I
think that might be the last state where
you can still smoke inside or at least
in comedy clubs or something there was
something kind of sexy about I kinda
funny how quickly that Oh change yeah we
were gonna go I have a friend who I
travel with a lot and so I just was
writing an essay amount
this so I've been going back not you
Justin Diaries but we were going to go
to northern Macedonia hmm and she found
us a hotel and it was like the best
hotel in town
and under amenities it listed toilet
paper you know you expect like a 24-hour
fitness center and spa business center
toilet paper water Macedonia and will
not put that on the top of my list if
that is a luxury I'm gonna ask you a
couple more things before I let you go
you need to leave I know I'm gonna fight
tooth and nail to keep you as long as I
can
you made this observation once that I
just loved so much about how when you
learn an animal's name you make a
judgment about them mmm so you don't ask
people their pets names or else you
would make a judgement that is so
fascinating to me that happens with
children a lot I mean I'll be having
someone come and get a book signed you
know
Oh sighs enjoy the Tyler uh well even
like Sione told you just one or son
Kievan hey even the ah but my favorite
was Draven which sounds like the past
past tense of Drive just like we were
drivin to the restaurant
I made a judgment about the parent first
no to cuz I'm like yeah asshole will
name their kid this yeah it really it's
loaded yeah it's so wild and where do we
get that from just our sort of in our
hippocampus we have judgments about
names from people we knew who already
had those names no weird stereotype we
didn't know I think part of it is you
know like the whole Atticus mm-hmm I
think I grew up in North Carolina and so
in North Carolina like what's your
mother's maiden name
this is wild and a lot of people might
not believe me but my dad's name was
Ehrich Cummings and my mom's was patty
coming huh
and they
married so it's coming Cummings huh okay
because your name or there's some in
breeding there I don't know but that was
it so it's coming and comings my mom's
maiden name was coming with no s because
often in the South your mother's maiden
name would be your first name mhm
so there was a formula to it but then
people started thinking well gosh what
would happen if I took Stephen and just
changed it to a K you know Kievan sounds
good and so and so these these bullshit
names so much moonshine yeah yeah
cropped up and that's what's in you know
this has been always interesting to me
and it's a really hard thing to you and
I spent Thanksgiving with this trans
woman uh last year and she's 70 and her
name is Madison now there was no
seven-year-old no named Madison you know
and but it's like with Caitlyn Jenner
that's a young that's a young woman's
name as well Caitlyn so you never meet
like she didn't think Ruth no Bonnie
Esther
Bonnie Diodati really interesting to me
that you can't be an 80 year old Kaylee
no you can't help and that's why we're
doing when you're working on something
the name really matter you know the name
of a person really matters and because
the name is gonna tell the reader how
old that person is and sometimes what
area they're from yeah so many things
but I also find that there is also even
within normal names now people are doing
these creative Spelling's like sometimes
oh oh yeah signing books and it'll be
Ashley and I'll be like no a sh le IgH
I'm like no but a lot of times you ask
it's like the mother allowed them to
change the spelling of their name the
parents did when the kid was like 14
that happens a lot that's and you can
never never allow your child to change
their name or the spelling of their name
ha because I mean when they're 14
because that's when you make the worst
decisions of all your life I used to
lick batteries when I was 14
I shouldn't be making any decision you
go back to North Carolina what mmm
we have a house on the beach there so I
go there when we go to that my dad's
still in Raleigh so you know I'll go and
see him
there's a wonderful comedy club outside
Raleigh and Cary uh-huh Cary
yeah yeah right outside yeah I think
it's an improv it's brand-new it's
gorgeous
hmm because I grew up in Raleigh
so I met somebody a while ago I was on a
book tour and I met somebody I was in
North Carolina and I said where do you
live and he said I live in Cary and he
thought I wasn't familiar with North
Carolina and he said that's like the
Beverly Hills of Raleigh oh there is not
a Beverly Hills wrong there just isn't
like there isn't a granite Village at
all it's like the soho overall not i
guess the last thing that i sort of want
to bring up it III was so you know i
talk about addiction a lot on this
podcast and something you said in the
master class that was so touching to me
that I had never heard it put this way
I've spent so much time and you know
talked about being an al-anon and
dealing with family members that are
alcoholics and addicts and stuff myself
identifying essentially as an addict you
said something that was just so simple
and I think it's so important for all
artists and just people in general to
think you said I'm a lot of Alcoholics
are good people
yeah do you remember saying that well I
wrote a story about my mother's drinking
and my mother was a really good person
who was an alcoholic who couldn't stop
drinking and it didn't make her a bad
person
it didn't make her a bad mother it just
made for a sad story you know when you
to think that somebody because maybe I'm
wrong but I don't think you can be that
happy and be an alcoholic you know what
speaking as someone who's an alcoholic I
I just felt trapped and I just felt like
I was sinking and I just felt like there
was no every day was the same yeah
and in a lot of days are going to be the
same sober right but there's still the
possibility that it can be different
when you're sober if no other reason
if you drink you drink that much beer
you can't go anywhere
no because you got a P that's right like
every three minutes so you can't really
go anywhere and then I would get high on
top of it and then I would be paranoid
and I couldn't go anywhere and I don't
know I just it and but and I think about
that all the time like how great it
would have been you know if my mother
could have quit drinking just how how
much better her life was cuz it was just
and luckily she wasn't like that all of
our childhood you know it just got
progressive and but we loved her yeah
and I never doubt that she loved me and
it was just but I don't I don't feel the
need I don't know I don't I don't I
don't judge her for it
I just did you spend time like learning
about the disease of addiction or it's
just was you knew in your heart what
about my mom yeah oh yeah I mean I just
knew you know I mean uh you know you
just saw it yeah
and just I mean knowing that it's not
really a choice that it's a sort of
chemical dependency over which she
doesn't have control when you're like
okay no one you know take me long time
learn no one wakes up and chooses to be
an alcoholic no one wakes up and is like
you know how I want to spend my day
isolating and drinking and you know not
getting anything done and then feeling
consumed a shame the next day it took me
so long to realize that it wasn't a
personal attack on me when other people
drank okay so well her dad was an
alcoholic and he you know had shock
treatments and you know the whole the
whole nine yards so she grew up with
that and
but it was a kind of thing I mean nobody
like I never said to my mother like what
can I do to help you like you've got to
stop drinking I and we were all afraid
to say that and if you even my dad
didn't say anything you know but okay so
like somebody needs somebody I feel like
somebody needs to have an intervention
with me and just say look you really
look awful in those clothes there I mean
you you really look awful and you can't
be you're not buying Renaissance roughly
capes in Japan you can't see it but
everybody else sees it but if they said
that I would think you don't know what
you're talking about yeah I would deny
it yeah and so it's not gonna change
until I say okay but one of the things I
got when I was in Japan yeah it's a pair
of Matador is met flamenco sleeves
yeah that's ball detachable yeah and so
there's elastic on one end and there
it's a cuff on the other and you can put
it on over another shirt yeah because
let's say you had a flamenco do they
make the shirts with the whole flamenco
sleep but let's say someone said come on
over we're having tacos you'd be like
flamenco showed I can't talk us but this
way you just take them all tap them
right uh-huh yeah we're gonna have tacos
oh and then you can do the dishes
this sounds like how an alcoholic
rationalizes behavior
yes no I see how you need an
intervention I see the parallel or let's
say you're paralyzed sister it says we
changed my tampon it's like I have my
Fomenko sleeves on I can't be doing that
but you just take them off I appreciated
that so much to have any questions for
me well what are you gonna do tonight
tonight I'm gonna stay in and probably
spiral
about all the questions I feel like I
forgot to ask you I'll probably spend a
couple hours just consumed with you know
shame and paranoia I should have asked
this and I should have asked that I'll
probably do that for a while
when's your next show uh tomorrow night
I do shows pretty much every night where
and where you gonna be tomorrow tomorrow
night only be the comedy star huh in LA
how long will you be on tomorrow when
I'm in town when we're up at the comedy
show we really only do 15 minutes 15
minutes you know just working on new
stuff and then I don't start going on
tour until March and that's when I think
about when you go on tour I have your
tour dates I go I think I start April
2nd or something like that and then and
then you're on tour you do what is this
20 30 cities a lot of cities it's like
45 or something Ashley it's like 45 this
is a wild number of cities this you come
with you oh god no no no new new new
you're in rhode island norfolk lexington
kentucky you might be able to see
Lynchburg Virginia oh look at you but
you you know like when I was young and I
would you know you would watch like say
some late night show yeah and then
somebody would say I'm gonna be playing
tomorrow I'm gonna be playing in in
Davenport Iowa and you'd think oh man
you lose her but you know anybody can
it's not that hard to fill a theater in
Los Angeles or Chicago or New York if
you couldn't fill the house in Davenport
yeah that's saying something no this is
a big I'm looking at these dates yep
Northampton Massachusetts yeah you for
instant you don't you don't make it easy
on yourself but in it and I think people
really appreciate you know that you go
to you know the smaller cities as well
Milwaukee fantastic Baton Rouge
Louisiana Miami Florida that's gonna be
hectic well the thing about a small town
like that is there's not a nice hotel no
I'll trust me oh I know and when people
say like oh my god how do you do it how
do you go to 45 cities when you're at
the Four Seasons or the Mandarin
Oriental not that hard yeah you know all
right man but if you're at an emeritus
fellow who I know who will come to see
me a lot and I was given free tickets
found it oh come to show the show oh
yeah
it comes to show that's and I always
give him free tickets cuz I get free
tickets to everything and he stays in
the worst places and he stated the
Amyris weeds and there was shit
on his shower curtain no no no no no no
and he went there's a front desk
yeah to complain about it and you know
the guy the front desk said it wasn't
mine that that was that's not an
acceptable answer
I used to torch so much I wouldn't used
to do about 80 cities a year after I'd
been doing stand-up for a couple years
or got my first special I bought a house
it was so important to me to buy a house
because I grew up at around alcoholic Oh
a lot of noise hectic I grew up in an
apartment a lot with people above us
all I wanted was quiet so I buy house
and I had no idea about property tax
inspections mmm I buy a house and I have
about $15,000 cash total leftover so I'm
basically house poor so I go on tour I
do 80 cities in a year I'm doing
colleges Monday Tuesday Wednesday then
going to do clubs doing two three shows
a night on July 4th I'm in Las Vegas and
I'm staying at a place called the South
Pointe casino which is off that the five
miles off the strip it's known as being
the home of the penny slots you go in
there it's like walking dead people are
limping around the buffet is like
Chinese food and chocolate pudding I
mean it is the most that it is a sad
scene and I'm there on July 4th which is
already performing on a holiday is
already kind of sad and lonely and I'm
like you know what I need to get some
air because when you're in Vegas you can
be inside for like three days right not
notice you start going a little too Jack
Nicholson in the shining you start going
crazy
so I'm like I need to go outside and get
some fresh air I need to just go to the
gym I go down to the gym and I go into
the bathroom to pee and I smell puke you
know that that puke smell where it's
just like sour and at whew
and I smell it right away and I'm like
oh god someone must have puked keep
moving pee go up to the wash my hands
and I'm like that's that's pungent I
mean it's like an effluvium of really
like sharp puke and I looked down and I
had actually stepped in human shit Wow I
picked up my shoe
took it off without thinking put it in
the sink started scrubbing it like full
out damn spot
Lady Macbeth I mean with but without
even thinking about it and then just
started hysterically crying
and just like I said of fools like
meltdown went up to the hotel room and
called Southwest to try to cancel the
show and get out of there I couldn't get
a flight out I ended up talking to this
woman on Southwest Airlines for about 45
minutes crying about how I just touched
human shit and she got me through it and
we still email to this day crystal hey
and there is something about seeing
someone else's shit that just something
snaps it's like a primal thing of like
I've worked too hard to smell some shit
have you been to China yes Hong Kong you
see no Hong Kong encounter oh man LAN
China then no you see turds everywhere
and I went in January they were frozen
yeah and I was in a lake and I thought
oh those people are ice skating around
sweet potatoes no they were turds and
every day I saw so many turds and you
would go into the bathroom and it would
just be turds in the toilet
people would just leave him I mean
they'd wouldn't flush they would just
leave it fry leave it for the next
person No and I saw it was just
interesting to be in a place where you
saw that many turds maybe it's like you
know like we're divorced from where our
food comes from totally you know but but
this this was it just made you think
well I guess we're all just basically
animals you asked correct yeah well I
just have so many questions it's just
like I have to wipe after I mean like
what what happens there what made me
think of I was reading something about
how when you pick up trash so often you
find soiled Underpants yeah when you're
picking up trash which is just tell such
a story I mean so many people shit their
pants yeah I found Underpants with turds
in them Nessa nested in them and okay
this is it I found a pair in the in the
rain a pair of briefs with potato sized
turd and slugs feast
yeah feasting so do you have like tongs
or something you've some kind of oh yeah
okay you have a whole thing and you've
got gloves on yeah yeah you look full
decks know I'm gonna have gloves I mean
I have them if I need I mean I have a
system I have gloves in my backpack if I
need them uh-huh but I carry a lot of
bags so I can take that sir
dump the turd take the underpants put
some leaves mix some leaves on them put
him in a plastic bag put that bag in
another bag oh my so and then dispose of
it I'm fine with dog shit I look at dog
shit I pick it up a horse shit I grew up
around horses human shit I just I can't
do it well it's funny how you can always
tell it's a human turd always oh why is
that why is that is it the size that we
just know the bits the color of it it's
kind of a cross that forms what it's our
processed foods we eat or something the
coffee but now I'm gonna ask what I know
everybody is thinking which is why don't
you have a podcast and are you gonna
ever have one I think it just takes too
much work mm-hmm you know yeah to have a
podcast I mean I think a lot of people
ike podcasts yeah and I think a lot of
people have podcasts especially when
they're sitting around with their
friends yeah and they're kind of talking
but it's not is interesting as they
think it is that's what I say and
everyone argues with me I'm always like
how is this interesting to anybody and
then people always tell me especially
convenience oh my god they just want to
hear a conversation doesn't have to be
that interesting and I'm like I feel
like I'm bombing well you know like one
of the podcasts I like is unlike the
Dana Gould hour and he puts you know a
little Hollywood history lesson in there
and he I don't know he seems to put a
whole lot of work into it and I always
laugh I mean I always find myself
laughing out loud
listening to that and most of the other
ones probably are I did you were
listening to super-ego no oh I think
I've subscribed to it what is it it's
Matt Gormley isn't your name look it up
and and just some other improv are
and they're really really incredibly
skilled and huh and it's funny in a way
that nothing else is funny is it live
they've done a few live shows but
usually I think they do it in a studio
Jeremy Carter in Long Beach they do it
they've done 79 episodes I'm gonna get
that that's really funny I like hardcore
history too that's that really he puts a
lot of work into it I mean that's like a
four-hour sort of thing he writes a lot
but you got he would just it would be
the biggest thing gosh I don't I mean
maybe if I had guessed but it would be
guests like this fireman that I know
well that would be the most interesting
I would this guy in England and he's
like six seven and he is so handsome it
does it doesn't he's a freak almost oh
so handsome
and women you know just just fall for
him and he loves women and he I don't
know he would be a like the first guest
on my podcast and you're just gonna ask
like we went to a restaurant together
and he said this would be a good place
to take birds because I don't
necessarily hear British people say the
word birds bird means hot hot girl or is
that like our chicks bring chicks yeah
yeah but it's a pejorative no no it's
just kind of old-fashioned it's a great
place to bring some cunts it's just
old-fashioned yeah you know bring some
birds and I had I don't know that I had
heard and so and there's a cashier at
the supermarket that I go to this is
already the best podcast i vet how have
you not started this yet and i wouldn't
mind her as a guest yeah I suppose but I
think they would just be you know normal
people then I would have on it's just so
wild to think about I mean morning
edition we were talking about this
earlier it had like about it was like
averaging 10 million listeners I mean
that's three times as big as any
scripted comedy show right now on
television yeah but I went from I think
the biggest audience that have was
five hundred but that wasn't just me I
was on a bill with other people oh Allah
so I went from five hundred to ten
million so that was quite a lead did you
know at the time when you were doing
that how many people I never listen to
Morning Edition
I was always asleep then I listened to
all things considered yeah but to me
part of having good life meant being
asleep and Morning Edition was on yeah
because it comes out like it I don't
know what six or something it starts so
yeah it just that's a lot of that's a
lot of people um and it you know I mean
it just but I'm not even on it that much
anymore I mean I have a show my own show
on the BBC mm-hmm and I do that but I've
been on NPR in years but still people
remember things from it which is nice
what do you watch do you watch shows or
I told myself I could only watch any
kind of a TV show if I'm on the
elliptical machine okay
so I put things on my iPad and then I go
to the fitness center okay and I was a
liar said it's not a doctor I was last
person to get ya to get Netflix did last
person I've had it like for six weeks
and they're a great show son I'm here to
tell you what have you discovered of
master of none yeah yeah yeah uh I think
that's a really good show well stood out
guys have got to watch this show
Seinfeld friends it's this new show that
just came out take a place in the 90s
it's a period piece and sometimes uh-huh
you know start watching the show and
then abandon it uh-huh
then there's just that always another
one to pick up yeah oh it's great yeah
so master of none you like yeah like
dramas yeah like drama
I like succession do you want unbeliev
my favorite show on to everybody
that's hole killer but what saves it as
the writing is so good brilliant that
you've intimate performances just unreal
yeah really like that I like there a lot
of shows that I have ideas I mean I'm
not a TV person but okay The Walking
Dead Yeah right like I like to see a
zombie eating somebody yeah right okay
so I just stuck with the walking dead
all this time right but all right and
this is a really good idea there'd be
nothing scarier if you had a choice
between open your door and finding a
lion there or zombie or finding a
chimpanzee
what kind of lion male or female let the
most savage lion that was like wounded
and hungry and a chimpanzee yeah I feel
like I would choose lion because it
would kill me faster whereas it would
just kill you different but the
chimpanzee the thing the thing about
chimpanzees killing people is that they
would bite your face off like why would
you start there yeah I mean it seems
like a weird place
I like biting someone's head uh-huh and
if you're a guy they rip your balls your
balls off they know to go straight for
the day so here's what I think okay in
the zombie apocalypse yeah
chimps escaped from zoos mm-hmm and they
all formed a big tribe yeah
now on the walking dead they don't have
guns anymore that's your enemy right
there chimps chimps like chitters could
completely destroy everything get over
that fence with no problem here's the
biggest question are there zombie chimps
you wouldn't even
well zombie chimp would just move like a
zombie so yeah I got it got it
but it's the Move class moving and like
that's such a good idea versus humans
like Game of Thrones jimpson humans
please go picture show we're like a
roller girlz balls off welcome to my
master class but sometimes I don't have
ideas for that Minnie
shows but every now and then I thank
gosh they really need to hear from me
yeah no I agree aware that is almost as
good as I remember when I heard the idea
for snakes on a plane uh-huh and I was
like we should all just pack up and go
home yeah a bunch of snakes get loose on
a plane I can't imagine anything more
carefully Hollywood's over pack up your
suitcases they did it it's so you can't
follow that okay but but chimps on a
plane ships on a chimps on a cruise
about perfect
chimps on a train chimps on a cruise
ship that's the best idea I would go
overboard immediately um did you hear
that
this is funny I thought where did I hear
this husana was on YouTube Paula Lynn
yeah you know he used to be on Hollywood
Squares
they and he was such a queen and when I
was young no one would ever say they
were homosexual but you looked at Paul
land and he just knew as a gay man you
thought oh he's gay min and they said to
him if a man falls overboard and people
yell man overboard
what do you yell if a woman falls all
overboard and he said full speed ahead
oh I hope to see you guys in the
comments for that one I have so much
more to ask you but I can't keep you
this long now I'm just being selfish at
this point I have no idea what time it
is it's 2:00 a.m. I missed dinner
we're both in a low blood sugar so a
good thing I got you actual sugar as one
of your thank-you gifts I put a very
weird gift bag together for you I hope
you like it
I was so kind of you I really appreciate
know it this is an honor I we've had a
lot of very fancy people in
here and you are definitely the person
that everyone has geeked out Oh most
yeah gosh I never expect that yeah
everyone is just completely geeking out
and not only that but before you came
we're usually goofing off and horsing
around and just being dickheads and
before you came every were just like
really silent nervous
panicky gosh that's so hot to me I don't
never expect your legend you know I
don't think it's fair if somebody
accused me recently he said you know you
abused your power you know you're
signing books and you abuse your power
who said that
or somebody who you're a comedian so
let's say if somebody told you something
mm-hmm right and it wasn't something
like about somebody else it was like
something that maybe something they did
or whatever okay what do you use that on
stage yeah yeah yeah yeah oh okay so his
point was you're taking the stuff people
share with you and using it onstage as
an artist yeah well yeah no my whole
thing is it's the second you come up and
speak to me all bets are off everything
you say can and will be used in
materials well I feel to that if you
don't want me to repeat it then say
don't repeat it
and I guess and it's not like I used the
person's name right so I don't I don't
and and I think it's different if you're
because like you said I mean one thing I
feel the same as you is that I mean I'm
not a comedian but I mean you're always
looking for things and you're always
looking to connect things and you're
always looking for a story and you're
always looking for and it's I mean I
think as a writer I mean it's sad but I
mean you're really kind of exploiting
everyone and everything you come you
come into contact with everyone spotter
yeah but I do think people don't always
like having a mirror held up it's
uncomfortable you know sometimes the
cute observations are they feel like a
tax but I've but I but it's just
interesting I feel like power
so often is in somebody else's eyes like
it's not in your own yeah sitting you're
thinking like I'm the most powerful
person in this room you're not you're
just sitting there and you're so
grateful the people came and they have I
don't know it's almost like they have
the power because if they stop coming
that's so true you're nobody so you're
not sitting there thinking hmm and I
feel like Fame is that way too like
famous other people's idea
yeah I'm not famous I mean I'm not
famous but I'm talking about if I meet
somebody who's famous that's something
I'm putting on them they're not it's my
idea of them being famous they've become
like a Rorschach test or you project
yeah reject projection machine know it's
interesting I mean I think you know and
we've actually talked about this you
know before on the show I think it's
when maybe Jim Jeffries was here about
especially the stuff we talked about and
the stuff that you know you know we
write about we tend to go into risky
areas that trigger people you know there
was a when Jim Jeffries was on stage in
Australia once he did a joke about
suicide and someone ran up on stage and
punched him in the face it's this what
will you pull it up I think we've even
why would they punch him in the face
because he probably just walked into a
hornet's nest of someone going through
something crazy and you know I think a
lot of times when we talk about things
that are is this it yes he made a joke
about suicide and someone just ran up on
stage this is before he got really
famous and attacked him Wow that person
really is attacking it isn't no why
don't you just never know what pain
you're walking into you know you don't
you never know what personality disorder
you're walking into or what mental
illness or what well that's the thing
too about it trigger warning because you
don't have any idea what's gonna set
people often that's right you know
that's right any idea and so I don't I
just sometimes feel like saying if you
have a problem with anything you should
leave mm-hmm but don't leave while I'm
here wait till I'm done wait till my
performance is over and then you but I
don't know that people are more
sensitive now
I think it's just it's free became free
to complain yes and because it used to
be enough to put a stamp on it and you
would think is this really worth free to
come 35 cents and then it became free
yeah and then so people's like I went to
sell years show and I went to get a coke
and I said I didn't want much ice and
they put a lot of ice in it it's like
you I can't believe you're wasting your
finger writing that everyone just wants
to be heard
it is really wild and not only is it
free I think it actually gets you some
cloud or something people get a couple
likes and like yeah look at you standing
up for yourself like not you you know
and it's almost rewarded at this point
for complaining I don't know what's
wrong with me I just don't get offended
I mean I don't you don't internalize it
no I get angry sometimes but I can't
think of but I think you also I was
thinking about it as you know I was
watching your class and we're talking
about how you observe people and I feel
like when you're as observant as you are
and is a good of a writer as you are you
always have to lead with empathy like
you're not necessarily internalizing
what people do because you're kind of
seeing them as a character in a story
you know that's usually how I'm able to
get out of it hmm that make sense it's
almost like a non-judgmental meditation
is how it felt like it's the kind of
thing - and you don't want to be
formulaic about it but I mean it seems
like if you're gonna give other people a
hard time you know you kind of need to
be hard on yourself as well right and so
sometimes people are like oh then you
did this and this thing and I didn't
like you anymore
and it's like well that's just a chance
I had to take because usually it's the
worse things you can admit that most
people can relate to
mm-hmm that's wild and I do find I
started every now and then I've started
responding to people who come at me only
card and I would say 95% of the time I'm
so sorry
I didn't think you were gonna see this
huh I love you so much I didn't mean
that sorry I was a dick you know well I
think there's a little bit of like I
just need to throw a rock at somebody to
make myself feel better and then if you
go to their profile you see that they do
it to a lot of people
huh and it's just some kind of addiction
and our adrenaline addiction or some
kind of needing to be seen or pulling on
people's pigtails or I only meant that
one comment about those culottes and
that detachable collar and that's the
only time I've ever commented on
anything on the Internet only time I
love you so much what an honor thank you
for being here
gosh thank you so much for having me in
your beautiful beautiful huh oh gosh
what a dream you're a dream such a fan
I'm gonna try to not a good place to
have a dream in a dream house oh I have
to pee I'd be so bad
[Music]
[Applause]